one big racial question that's up right
now is whether or not
uh we will have reparations for slavery
you've heard this for the first time
in a major presidential race a huge
number of the candidates are saying they
support
reparations for slavery and even joe
biden has supported a commission to talk
about whether or not we should have
reparations
so don lemon will go half of tweedle
eastweedledom on cnn
don lemon brings up this question of
reparations and
columbia professor john mcquarter who is
a liberal but he's a little more
reasonable as far as liberals go
he goes on the show and he says don
whether or not you want reparations or
not
we've already had them i'm a little wary
of the idea
that we should think of that as a
microcosm for what should happen for
black america because
not because i'm against reparations but
because reparations for black america
already happened starting in the late
60s affirmative action
was reparations people didn't use that
word but that's precisely
what it was the community reinvestment
act of 1977 that forced
banks to invest in inner cities nobody
makes a movie about that
but that was reparations of affirmative
action
didn't help to turn black america upside
down then why do we fight
red tooth claw and nail whenever anybody
threatens it it created a huge black
middle class
and it created black success of all
kinds that wouldn't have happened
without it i think affirmative action
was a great thing but
i do think that it was a reparation i
love this argument i love the angle he's
taking here because he's saying look
some kind of reparation
is perhaps justified and this was the
opinion of
basically everybody after the civil war
right they said 40 acres and a mule that
was going to be the promise because
you can't just say to a huge number of
people
okay you've you've got your freedom now
but you don't have
any property and you don't really have
many political rights and you've got
people who are
really opposed to you having political
rights and okay so it'll work out fine
right
no it probably won't now should we have
reparations
hundreds of years later i think that
argument's a little weaker
but to me the clever argument is we've
already had them
of course and of course we have if
affirmative action if the racially
focused welfare programs of the last
60 years in this country are not a
reparation
then what the hell are they what's the
point of them if they're not a
reparation get rid of them if we're
gonna if we're gonna do something else
now
then we absolutely need to scrap all of
those programs if it's not a reparation
why do black students get preferential
treatment when they apply to college
why why are white students and asian
students
put at a disadvantage they have to score
higher on the sat they have to get
better grades they have to do better
than the black students to get into the
same colleges
that's a reparation well okay if it's a
reparation then
we've already got it but what this shows
you
and this i think is the brilliance of
the quarter's argument here
he hasn't even come to this conclusion
explicitly but i think it's it's implied
the one of the arguments against
reparations is what do you think is
going to happen we're going to
okay 10 billion dollars there you that's
the reparations we're good now it's all
good
no more racial grievance of course not
it's never
going to end there's no end point to
that and
the proof of this is we've already tried
it and there was no end point to it
hey there before you go make sure you
ring that bell you subscribe you like
you get the notifications
you can head on over to apple podcast
google play spotify
stitcher all those places subscribe to
the audio podcast we really appreciate
it you can leave a five star review and
oh what
oh oh this thing are you oh this is my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available
now for pre-order it's dropping on june
22nd you can get
a signed first edition copy of premiere
collectibles this one i actually i'm
glad i have the physical copy so i can
prove to you
this one unlike my first book has actual
words in it go check it out
see you next time